As we continue to follow the absolute tragedy
that is taking place in Texas with power outages,
people without hot water, people
without heat, people struggling to get
food. We talked yesterday about
Republican Texas Governor Ted Cruz
flying off to Cancun with his family to hit
the beach. That was Ted Cruz's approach.
Beto O'Rourke, former Democratic Senate
candidate and presidential candidate,
decided instead to phone bank and call elderly
folks to see if they were OK. But he also is
making some very appropriate and very harsh
comments about Texas leadership actually going
as far to say that Texas is approaching a failed
state status better, O'Rourke said. First of all,
so much of this was avoidable. Going back to the
deregulation of our electric grid here in Texas,
which has actually created an incentive to not
weatherize or protect against these events better.
O'Rorke Absolutely right. As we've told you
before, in 2011, Texas had power outage issues.
An extensive report was compiled saying do these
things to protect yourselves in the future. They
weren't done. And it happened again, absolute
negligence by Republican leaders in Texas.
But then that's going further and saying
the energy capital of North America cannot
provide enough energy to warm and power people's
homes. We are nearing a failed state in Texas,
and it has nothing to do with God or natural
disasters. It has everything to do with those
in positions of public trust who have failed us.
People have died in Texas and tens of thousands
are still in the dark and cold. And you would
think maybe they'll change their tune on going
it alone and separating from federally managed
power grids. Maybe they would change their
tune on climate change. Doesn't really mean
anything, because as climate science predicts,
you have a radically hot and a radically cold
weather events that are part of a broader shift
in climate, often to the warmer. But that doesn't
mean you don't have outrageously cold or erratic
snowstorms in places that don't typically have
them. And of course, if you try to bring that up,
Texas Republicans will now hide behind
that tired old trope. This is not the time
to politicize a tragedy, is what they will say.
Well, it also wasn't the time to politicize it
in 2011 when this happened. And you got a report
saying, hey, here's what you should do and you did
nothing about it. So I'm glad that better O'Rourke
is saying these things. I worry, however, that
he is sort of yelling into the void because there
are so many Republican Texas officials, Ted Cruz,
former Governor Rick Perry, current Governor Greg
Abbott, Lieutenant Governor Dan Patrick. These
people don't seem willing or remotely interested
in seeing reason. Let's hope let's hope that by
Monday we have better news about the circumstances
for tens of thousands, if not hundreds of
thousands or even at the sort of top, top level
millions of Texans that have been affected by this